المستعمر الذي يفرض ارادته صوره ذهنيه
تشعر بها الدول الافريقيه تجاه اوروبا لم
تاتي من فراغ طبعا وكثيره ما وقفت عائقا
امام تقدم العلاقات اليوم تحاول اوروبا
تغير تلك الصوره وتحويلها الى الشريك
الموثوق والهدف المعلن والدعم لكن هناك
اهداف خفيه وقف اشكاليه الهجره غير
الشرعيه ومواجهه تمدد النفوذ الصيني
والروسي في القاره
طرق مختلفه اتخذتها اوروبا تنظيم وقيمه من
اخرها في ابريل 2022 لكنها الختامين تضمن
عبارات عامه
سنواصل معالجه جميع جوانب الهجره والتنقل
ودون التطرق مثلا الى كيفيه معالجه
اسبابها
اعاده متاحف الاوروبيه للقطع الفنيه
الافريقيه التي نهبت خلال الحقبه
الاستعماريه قضيه حساسه اخرى لم يتطرق
اليها البيان الختامي رغم اشاره رئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي للعام المنصرم الرئيس
السنغالي الباكال لها بوضوح
الموجود في الخارج هذا الامر يمثل اولويه
القصوى بالنسبه لافريقيا هذه القطعه
الاثريه تمثل جزءا منهياتنا وتاريخنا اذا
اردنا بناء مبادئ عقلانيه بين افريقيا
واوروبا يجب ان تبنى على الاحترام
والاعتراف بالحقائق التاريخيه
[تصفيق]
بعيدا عن موقف اوروبا الجماعيه هناك خطوه
ايجابيه فبعد عقود من الرفض والانكار شهد
العام المنصرم اعلان عدد من دول القاره
اعاده التحف الفنيه التي تم الاستيلاء
عليها من افريقيا على مدى قرن ونصف
هي مبشره لكن الطريقه طويله بل وطويل جدا
نتيجه للنهب الكبير على مر القرون حتى
عندنا اوروبا تمتلك قطعا اثريه افريقيه
قديمه اكثر من افريقيا بيحددتها المتحف
الملكيه البلجيكي لافريقيا الوسطى وحده
ويضمه 180 الف قطعه